welcome back everybody las vegas
restaurant week is coming up and it
encourages people to dine out for a good
meal
a good value and a good cause you don't
need many more incentives than that i
stopped by one of the participating
restaurants and to see
what's on the menu
hey rocky i'm chef west table 34 welcome
to my kitchen thank you
we're so happy to be part of restaurant
week i want to show you a couple items
that we're going to be doing on our menu
so what what is what's the menu like
here at the table 34 what kind of food
do you guys have
we're a contemporary american restaurant
a lot of fresh seafood
homemade pastas pizzas we've got
everything a little bit of dirt lamb
duck all kinds of good stuff
okay good good to know so we want to
make sure that fish isn't going to stick
right into the pan get our vegetables
going here
and then we're going to plate it and
you're going to come in and help me do
it i'm going to plate it
i feel like the orange needs to you use
your artistic
thing look at that now we're going to
plate this salmon
right up top the watercress here and
we're going to garnish
oh my gosh it's a little lemon bill
butter
and then we're going to put a sprig of
dill right on top of that sample right
here
yeah you just grab a small piece it'll
go right on top of the sandwich
perfect beautiful las vegas restaurant
week is a 12 day event
this year it's being held june 7th
through the 18th
menus are live at restaurantweeklv.org
we have over 120 restaurants
participating this year
you can go on now check out the menus
make reservations at some of your
favorite restaurants
we have great things to choose from
three square has been hosting restaurant
week for over 10 years now
so our restaurant partners have been so
generous giving back to us for all of
those years
over a half a million meals have been
provided to
people here in southern nevada that need
help right now one in six people in
southern nevada is food insecure
so when you dine out with your friends
or with your family
what you're doing is enjoying some time
with them while feeding somebody else's
family here in southern nevada one of
the things that we're doing special this
year is
trying to do a little give back to the
restaurants many people haven't been out
to restaurants for the last year
so come and give back to your community
to the restaurants that have a long time
been supporting our community
and three square while at the same time
giving back to those who
need help in southern nevada it's so
nice to be off of zoom and breaking
bread together at a restaurant
yeah i know one of my favorite
restaurants but if you're not ready to
come into the restaurant
there are other options that you have as
well for restaurant week we do we have
multiple options this year for
restaurant week so the restaurants are
offering
um in inside service or that you can
dine out
there are takeout menu options available
also so
that's a really secret component to this
year we've got some takeout options so
everyone can come and enjoy and spend
some time with their family and friends
while helping out a really good cause
perfect and of course
great patios to eat on here in vegas
beautiful patio with little twinkle
lights and a little bit of air
conditioning so yeah if we get out of
here we can go there now
ambiance will ambience okay good well
thank you so much
i'm excited to celebrate with you guys
and help out three square thank you
cheers
what'd you say jc dining for a cause i
like that it was such a great restaurant
too by the way las vegas restaurant week
is june 7th
through the 18th just head to
restaurantweeklv.org for a complete list
of restaurants and menus and for more
information on the three square food
bank call 702-644-3663